But you've, have you been mobbed before? You have no. Yeah.
What's been the worst? Oh, one of the big ones was a about a trans fighter.
I remember that. Yeah. That was a hilarious one. Cause I'm like,
you guys can kiss my fucking ass. You're out of your mind.
You guys are out of your mind.
If you think that a man who has been a man for 30 years and has taken female
hormones for two is the same. You put Brock Lesnar,
chop his Dick off and put him in a dress,
that guy's gonna Maul through the women's heavyweight division.
Like nothing you've ever seen in your life.
Cause we're built different and it's just a fact.
And then they want to tries to argue that is crazy. And there are,
there's certainly standouts in terms of women who are, uh,
like much more muscular, higher bone density,
particularly African American women have very high bone density. Um,
but there's a different shape to their hips. There's a,
there's the size of the hands, the size of the shoulders.
Th things are different.
Also the imprinting of years and years of testosterone. It's just,
there was a great article by this, uh,
board certified endocrinologist who went over all of the,
all the things that separate men from women,
which shouldn't exclude them from competing in combat sports against women.
And this woman was called a trans phobe and she's a fucking endocrinologist.
And she's talking about the science and she's also talking about the science of,
one of the things they talk about is how women, you know, or a trans woman,
once they transitioned to being a woman,
they're basically biologically almost exactly the same as woman. She was like,
no, not only that,
but the bone density is retained by taking estrogen,
which is what the problem with women, when they have osteoporosis, they lose,
they're losing estrogen, they lose bone mass. Well,
the estrogen actually helps you retain bone mass.
So when a man transitions to a woman and then starts taking estrogen,
it's actually helping retain the bone mass that you would have lost by not
having testosterone. And then on top of that reaction times,
the Rita reaction times are several tenths of a second faster in general for
women than they are for eat or for men rather than they are for even
professional athlete women. So all of these,
all these variables that need to be taken into consideration when you're
allowing someone to do a sport. And we're not just talking about bike racing,
we're not talking about, you know, something where someone non-contact,
we're talking about the most contact, we're talking about fucking fighting.
There's, there's benefits that certain people have. There's,
there's physical attributes that P there's variables inside the genders, right?
There's some men that have gigantic physical advantages over other men and all
of those are taking into [inaudible].
There's no like even playing field when it comes to even enter gender
competition or, or you know, male versus male competition.
No real level playing field. So the best we can do is say, okay,
well you guys gotta be the same weight, let's just make that,
make it the same weight. And that's as close as you can get. But,
but even in that, there's people that are just physically, they're just,
they're just going to be better. There's no, there's no getting around it.
There's going to be better athletes. There's, they're,
they're going to have better genetics. You know,
there's nothing you do about that.
But one thing we can do is we can keep women from getting beaten up by men and,
and men who transition to being women. And if you think that's fair,
you're fucking crazy. And it's just not, it doesn't make,
it doesn't make any sense. And the arguments for it are so shitty.
And so they're so riddled with progressive speak that they're trying to pretend
that this is a woman. Now this is not a woman, this is a trans woman.
This is a male. She has a Y chromosome.
She transitioned to being a female. Now she's a trans woman,
and if you choose to fight her and you're a woman and you know that she's a
trans woman, I'm totally fine with that.
But that was not what was going on here.
What was going on here was this woman who used to be a man for 32 years,
transitioned to being a woman and it didn't tell anybody and thought two
different women who thought they were fighting a woman and got fucking smashed.
I was watching it. It was like watching a man fight a woman.
That's what I was watching. I was like, this isn't like particularly,
she wasn't particularly skillful.
It wasn't like she had like some unbelievable background and judo,
like Ronda Rousey or something like that.
It wasn't that you were just literally watching a former man beat up women who
never had the benefit of 30 years plus of testosterone in their body.
What do you think the solution should be then? I don't know,
but I was fascinated by watching the, the mob come after me for that one. Yeah.
I was like, this is, this is adorable, but what was fascinating about it was,
well, here's something that I, I mean I'm not a physio,
I'm not a real expert in physiology or endocrinology,
but I'm a martial arts expert and I've been doing it my whole life.
Like I know the difference. I've,
I've trained with women world champions and watched them get mauled by men who
are not very good. It's just a fact, especially when it comes to striking,
you know, there's more of a gap in jujitsu or, or the,
the gap rather closes in jujitsu because skill and technique take precedent over
physical strength. But God damn it when it comes to striking.
You could get a man who's been doing it for six months,
but just happens to have a lot of fast Twitch muscle fiber and it just knows how
to hit things hard and he, he'll fuck a woman up. It's not good.
Especially when it comes to kickboxing and kicking and punching. There's so,
there's so many advantages and to to say that those advantages are immediately
cut out of the picture.
As soon as you transitioned to being a woman and within two years he should be
able to fight women in a cage and not tell them, you're a woman. I was like,
this is insanity. Yeah. So that was the,
that was the big mob that came after me. Hmm.
I think it's interesting that in this,
because it is pitting people who would call themselves feminist against
transgender activists and it's basically women are being lost in the mix,
so you can't say certain things like what planet would it be okay for someone
who is born male to fight a woman, but in this case,
because this person who's born male identifies as female.
You can't call that into question,
but also there was a real problem in Texas the other way where they're there,
what they were doing is being prejudice against trans people to the point where
they wouldn't let a girl transitioning to being a boy wrestle with boys.
They made her wrestle with girls while she was taking testosterone.
It's like you guys are out of your fucking mind like you.
You're not even recognizing that she wants to compete with boys,
which is a disadvantage for her or him now let him compete with boys because
this is a different thing. But then even then a lot of boys were saying,
well look, I'm not taking testosterone.
I just have testosterone would have her testosterone is higher than my
testosterone because she's taking exogenous testosterone. This is kinda crazy.
Like yeah, it's, there's a lot of new ground that's going on here.
My concern as a,
a martial arts expert is when you are using ideology to push this,
this progressive notion that, you know,
a trans woman is exactly the same as a woman and you're getting women beat the
fuck up because of it. And this is what I felt and this is what I saw.
And they wouldn't have to be hard for like a year or two.
But then it all went away. What's the worst thing they said about you?
I didn't mean it. I didn't read it.
I read a little bit of it and then I was like,
Oh I really didn't even hurt my feelings cause I was like, this is so stupid.
It's like, do you know a woman who's got a hand that looks like that?
Find one, find one. Because if I took estrogen, I'd still have these.
And that's not fair. It's just not, I don't care.
I don't care what anybody says. It's just not mean. Even a woman with big hands,
they're not that big. They're not like Brock Lesnar's hands.
There's a difference. There's a fucking difference.
There's a difference in the shape of the jaw. There's a difference in,
so there's so many differences and men to women and there's so many women that
used to be men that transition to being women that are now dominating these
sports. Or these women feel like they're being fucked over, like weight lifting.
There was this Australian weightlifter who's a trans woman who's competing as a
woman and is fucking breaking records and left and right. And everybody's like,
this is crazy. She's an inspiration. Yeah. No, she's a guy.
She used to be a guy and now she's breaking these women's records. Like,
what are we doing? This is crazy.
Yeah, but to play devil's advocate, um, please do.
Didn't fall and Fox get beaten by Ashley Smith. Yeah,
because she sucks. That's really what it is. Actually. Evan Smith is good.
It shows she's so good. She listen. There's a lot of women.
That would be a lot of men, women who are not taking anything.
Who would beat a lot of men and it's happened. Um, uh,
uh, Jermaine Duran dummy who, uh,
was a super high level women's MMA fighter is uh,
won the 145 pound world title beat Holly Holm.
She fought a man in a kickboxing bout, knocked him out.
It's cause she's a fucking beast. She's really good and really technical,
super strong and just much better than a guy who wasn't on her level.
But she's just super exceptional.
But there's also women who fought men who were world champions,
who got knocked down, who there was a woman from, God damn it,
she was a, a female boxer from Holland.
Her name escapes me right now. She was,
she was a woman that they were always trying to ma match her up with Christy
Martin back when Christy Martin, the coal miner's daughter was a famous,
God dammit, why can't I remember her name? But she was a,
an elite female boxer and she got knocked out by a man. It was ugly.
And the guy she knocked out,
the guy who knocked her out really wasn't very good.
He just clanged her on the jaw and coyote her.
But it was disturbing to watch, but somehow it wasn't disturbing.
When Jermaine to random, he knocked out the guy. Then it was like, yeah, girl.
Yeah, the, you can't,
you're always going to have people that are higher level skill. And Ashley,
Evan Smith, who's competed successfully in the UFC, she's very tough.
And she beat vallum Fox. Yeah. And that citizen, you know,
I'm not against Fallon, Fox fighting women that want to fight her.
I'm not against that. If they want,
I'm not against women fighting men to want to do, I'm not a man.
I'm not against people riding bowls. I'm not against people bungee jumping.
I should be able to do whatever the fuck you want,
but don't pretend that you're exactly the same as a biological woman.
Well, why the fuck did we have tests then? Why me? Why? What is it?
What does a chromosome, what are genetics? What are, what is it? Is it all,
we're just going to give it all away for ideology. And what about women?
Like this idea of being completely progressive and and looking at things.
And and promoting equality. That's wonderful,
but are you promoting equality for women? Like what about the women?
What about a woman like you? What about a woman who's slight and thin? What do,
what are you supposed to do? How much do you weigh? I'm not going to tell you.
You're very fun. Okay. Let's pretend you're in the 105 pound weight class.
Do you feel like you can compete with the 105 pound man and know that seems,
this seems ridiculous, right? Well,
it seems to me that we have to accept the fact that there's some physical
differences when the consequences are being gravely injured and this is what
martial arts are all about.
I'm trying to hurt you and I shouldn't have natural physical advantages that
come from having a Y chromosome in 30 plus years of testosterone in my body.
That just seems to be obvious to me and I didn't understand why,
but that was a Hill that I was ready to die on. I was like,
you guys can fuck off for you for that,
but you see that they've kind of left you alone now. Right?
Because I do this cause I,
cause I can say things like this about it and I cause it makes sense.
And because when other people hear about it that are rational people, they go,
what? What's happening? Wait a minute, that's a guy. She was a guy for 30 years.
Like that's not right.
And the vast majority of people who even support trans rights,
including friends of mine who are trans are with me on this. They're like, yeah,
that's crazy. Have you heard the term turf?
Am I surf and turf turf?
No. Turf as in terf is trans exclusionary radical feminist.
So this is a new slur that's being used against women who will say trans women
are not women because they were not born women.
Whoa. Trans exclusionary radical.
So you would kind of be a turf in this situation cause you're advocating for
women and the safety of women and saying that people who are born male but
identifies female are not the same as people who are born female.
Yes. But that doesn't mean that I'm discriminatory. No,
it's a word that they use to try and discredit you. Good luck.
Have fun with that. I don't care see this a problem. But the,
the thing about this is I don't care because I really don't have any hate in my
heart and I don't have any discrimination in my heart. Like I don't do well.
I can't speak for everybody. Some do, but some do. I'm sure.
I'm sure if you were to look,
if you have a thousand people and a hundred of those people are a fucking
asshole to you, it's going to feel like a lot of people, right?
So if you're a trans person and you're you, I mean,
I've seen horrific things written to trans people online. I've seen it,
I've seen, I understand that there's real discrimination,
but I understand that you have to understand, Oh,
you have to appreciate who your actual allies and who people who are rational
people who actually care about you and who disagree with you on one very
particular thing, and this is the only place where I disagree.
It's combat sports and it's because it's my area of expertise.
I've been doing it since I was a kid. Like,
you can't tell me that there's not differences.
I've watched men and women fight my whole life. I know there's a difference.
And I know that from talking to endocrinologist and people who are experts in
the human anatomy,
that there's just physiological differences that are insurmountable. They are,
I've seen men
and women hit the bag. It's a very different thing. Yeah.
I mean I get where people are coming from, the people who are upset by this,
because I think by acknowledging someone that someone was not born,
the sex that they identify as, it's almost like saying,
pointing out to them that they're different, but they are different. Well, yeah,
but are different.
But I can see how that can be upsetting for someone who identifies as the
opposite sex.
Yeah. You know what? I can see how it's upsetting.
If you're short and you want to identify as being tall, you know what?
If I wanted to pretend that I was seven feet tall and you'd be like, Joe,
you're five, eight like are you an asshole?
Why are you saying I'm a five eight but you are.
So if I say you're a trans woman, which means you're a born a man, you haven't,
why chromosome? They're like, well you're a piece of shit cat.
How you point that out? Well that's what you are. It's not that you're negative,
uh, you are people who are dwarves or is that,
is it evil to say that a dwarf is a dwarf or a little person or whatever,
whatever phrase you want to use,
are we supposed to acknowledge that there's an issue?
Like if someone is born with a handicap, are you supposed to, is that a fact?
Are you allowed to discuss it as a fact if you have autism,
my allowed to bring up the fact that you are on the spectrum or am I supposed to
ignore it? Yeah. Is it discrimination? If you talk about reality,
if someone has a deformity,
are you allowed to discuss it or is it discrimination to discuss reality?
Because what are we doing with our language?
What are we doing with the way we describe the actual things that are,
that exist in the world?
And if we're not describing them in accurate terms cause we're trying to somehow
or another stop people from getting hurt feelings,
what are these feelings based on these delusional perceptions of reality and why
are we reinforcing these delusional perceptions of reality?
Because it seems to me that this kind of language and this kind of exclusionary
th th th th th the inability to use certain words and the inability to describe
things accurately, correctly, and in many cases,
scientifically it hurts everybody. Yeah,
I agree with that. I don't think facts themselves are hateful.
I think people who use facts to justify discrimination,
that's where the problem is. And that's where the efforts should be going.
Because when you start to deny facts, where does that leave you?
Where do you draw the line in that case?
Absolutely. But I think it's, there's something that's kind of cool about it,
that there are trans people.
And what's cool about it is that the world is weird. You know,
and I'm, I'm not happy that they get a lot of hate,
but I'm kind of happy that they exist.
I wish they could just be women.
I wish you could just like hit a switch and you really wish you're born a woman.
Bam, you're a woman. But I suspect that even if you could do that,
some people would rather just be trans.
Some people would look like there's a lot of people that I know that are trans
and also have dicks and they want to the deck. Yeah. And they're like, okay,
like what's going on here? And you, you know that you're transphobic.
If you're a straight heterosexual male and you're not willing to date a trans
woman with a Dick, but you know what it is,
it's actually a sexual preference for men who will date trans women who were
retaining their penis. That's what it's called in the literature.
They decided not to get surgery.
It's actually a particular sexual preference for the people that are attracted
to that particular trans woman. Andrea morpho. Phelia Whoa.
Someone tell Jim Norton.
Um, nothing wrong with that either. No, nothing. Nothing wrong with that either.
Do what you do. This is the thing, the difference between a man and a woman,
a trans man, a trans woman,
and then someone who could actually be a woman who transitions.
I think we're going to get to a point within, you know,
whether it's a hundred years or 500 years where we can use things like the,
the future version of CRISPR or whatever comes down the line.
Next,
some scientific innovation that's going to allow people to literally transition.